this is a production of Cornell
University
so thank you for having me I'm really
excited to be here most of the time I'm
talking to audience
audiences of artists which is one kind
of talk and one kind of audience but a
lot of what I do is really meant to be
bridging and translating vocabularies
between different disciplines and
addressing over specialization when we
have complex problems to address and
complex systems to deal with so as
you're honest men shinned I was a
faculty member for about 15 years at a
number of different art schools and my
work as an artist kept moving me closer
and closer to what I could only
understand as research and there was no
vocabulary in the art world for
conducting research by making art work
and so I left and became what I've been
told is now an independent scholar which
meant I needed an organization to back
me up and I invented one and so what I
do is I work with artists to recognize
that their process of making art is a
form of research and that research that
scientists or other artists or other
disciplines may do is also producing art
that they are related to each other and
a really important way so I'm gonna fly
through a bunch of material as quickly
as I can so that we can have a
conversation about it because I'm
particularly interested in what
questions you may have and how you may
see your own relationship to the kinds
of learning and the ways of knowing that
artists use so the first question maybe
you're all asking and I'm often asked is
what is it that artists actually do does
anyone have a quick pithy answer about
what artists do
sometimes it's like what do you do I'm
an artist and they're like okay I don't
know what that is but that's a good
answer
yeah observe the world create an
interpretation on it right so you're a
step ahead you're already like
recognizing that the observation that's
the big part right a lot of people say
well what do you do you make artists
make art right it's like they they look
at the interpretation look at the object
that artists are producing as the result
of being an artist
so it might be easier to comprehend if I
ask you what do scientists do what
anyone in this room say oh we make
science so there's a much better
vocabulary I think at least in the
sciences for what it is the scientists
do because there's there are systems
there are methods that's basically you
know science is understood as a means of
learning about the world there are
structures through which you you stage
your learning and the fact is that art
actually is the same thing so even
scientists also use the similar
vocabulary to artists right how do you
know if you've what you've done is
useful in science the thing works in art
we talk about the same thing an artwork
works like we can't necessarily describe
why because we haven't built up that
vocabulary that's a part of the problem
that kind of address among artists but
we recognize that something works and so
I see artists and scientist is
essentially cousins right we're related
to each other and we're related around
this idea that what we do is we learn
about the world we produce knowledge
about the world around and within us so
this is a super loaded slide with tons
and tons of historical implications that
you can take snapshot of and email me
about later but this is kind of a rough
Hydra of the creation of knowledge and
understanding particularly in the West
where once scientists and artists were
the same thing we were natural
philosophers I observed the world around
us we tried to make sense of it
then the Enlightenment came the
empirical method came and scientists
became scientists and no offense but at
the time the science wasn't very good
all right the method was good but the
but it was still very crude the result
of that was that artists became
romantics they looked at what scientists
were doing trying to break the world
apart and understand its constituent
pieces and artists said what about the
ineffable what about spirit what about
soul what about faith right and so art
and religion became bound together in
this idea of romance and that was
romanticism what I have called art
religion and then with modernism are in
religion had its own schism and so here
we see like a kind of disciplinary or
sort of knowledge production
categorizations vision so the thing is
that we so scientists could collect data
right like that is the empirical method
you observe you experiment you gather
data and then you synthesize that data
it makes sense it so artists do the same
thing but we don't have a vocabulary for
it so in art school we don't recognize
what kind of knowledge we're producing
we just create the objects and so what
artists produce this is what artists are
taught we are taught to make art ok we
bring it into class and we critique it
so what I do with artists literacies
Institute is I bring together artists at
all stages of their career and do these
interdisciplinary workshops I work with
artists one-on-one and I keep asking the
same question over and over again what
do you know and how do you know it so if
I ask an artist that that can be very
challenging for a lot of artists I just
have a hunch I can feel it I can sense
it right I use my intuition so I call
these things artists literacies you know
point that out and why why it is a
literacy in a moment but an artist
literacy they are senses there are
sensitivities they are our ways of
knowing
so every artist I believe may have
different ways of knowing and I suspect
that our artistic disciplines our media
our different ways of learning that
we've selected and reflect the
possession of unique literacies unique
ways of knowing about the world so the
reason it's a literacy is because a
literacy has to go in two directions if
you can just read but you can't write
you aren't fully literate if you can
write you can't read you weren't fully
literate and illiteracy doesn't
necessarily have to deal with only words
so most of the everyone in the room is
almost an environmental scientist a
scientist of some kind so I don't know
anything about environmental science you
know that's that's like I come in just
not knowing and that's all right so I
don't know anything about it I don't
know what you know and I don't know how
you know it I don't know about your
methods I could come to school here I
would probably learn a lot but as a
filmmaker if I spent a few weeks here
among you with a camera and spoke with
you and Biggers do talked with you and
watched I would start to learn a lot
about environmental science I would
learn it the way that I learned which is
I tell stories I make narrative and
causative connections between things and
the thing that might surprise you is
that in practice in doing this I may
actually learn things about
environmental science and environmental
scientists that you yourselves don't
know so having that observer present
right is can be a really very powerful
thing there are new things that we can
learn and that's because I have what I
call a literacy in narrative narrative
itself I would define as perceived
causation when you go and watch a movie
these different clips of footage are
stuck together and they make sense to
you because you perceive causation
between those clips that's the mental
and cognitive process that we visit in
an editing room and spend months poring
over does cut a make sense with cut be
if we think that an audience would
recognize causation between a and B then
there's a narrative connection the same
thing happens if I'm just sitting here
with a camera and I'm looking around the
room I'm making kind of very quick rapid
I'm reading right using my literacy I'm
reading I'm saying something people are
responding in a certain way and I'm
looking around and I'm making narrative
connections so this is a way of knowing
they don't teach that in film school
though so perceived causation and this
is a model project where I was testing
this in Uganda actually trying to
understand why elephant and ivory
bearing animal populations are declining
in some places in rising and others I
went in looking through the lens of
perceived causation so known as
narrative if we can tell a story about
why certain systems are working better
than other systems
maybe we can understand something
positive about it and this was a real
puzzle because across Africa certain
parts of East Africa we're seeing
elephant populations rise and certain
parts of seeing them fall and yet the
same interventions were being applied in
both of those places so there was
something different in one context as
opposed to another one and they didn't
know what it was and I said when maybe
if we told the story about it we might
be able to I'll be able to see something
we couldn't see so this is a kind of
visualization of what that cognitive
process to a filmmaker looks like when I
look at a film frame okay I don't
actually see these squares but these
squares represents a way of looking for
a filmmaker that is within a single
image there is a ton of material a ton
of visual information that I'm able to
read and I'm recognize Ono that my
audience is going to read how my
audience again sad to say is probably
mostly illiterate mostly visually
illiterate because we don't teach visual
literacy the way we teach verbal and
textual literacy but you will look at an
image and you will start to make very
quick evaluations about people
context tone mood emotion because you're
human beings right because you see that
thing you can perceive these things this
is the difference between being able to
watch a film and being able to make a
film anyone in the room can watch a film
it does take a lot of work and training
to be able to make a film so this is
within one film frame okay and there are
three categories of knowledge in that
film frame then the next film then the
next cut comes along and there's three
more categories of knowledge and they
speak to each other
so there's not only intramural or intra
frame information but there's also inter
frame information and it very quickly
multiplies and a film becomes a really
complex sight of knowing like cognitive
and subconscious knowing most of the
time you get to see that knowledge in
the form of a continuous stream of
scenes a film and I started to wonder
what it would look like if it wasn't all
in a line but if we were able to hop
around the media based on things like
decisions that got made behaviors and so
this is a map of narrative linkages
between different seasons in the film
that conceivably we could follow and
learn different things about the
characters in the film the people who
are living these experiences so all of
this is a kind of what we call coding
right you know we're doing it in an
editing room most filmmakers are not
doing it consciously it's a lot of just
dialogue and discourse in the editing
room does this work
it does not work you iterate you try it
again and again you show people rough
cuts right so it's a very again kind of
scientific method it just like yeah it's
there it's almost there it doesn't quite
work and then and then you end up with
the product but we only get known for
our product so that's how it works for a
filmmaker and then I started to wonder
well what about other forms of art
making what about other creative
practices
besides narrative what are these other
kinds of literacies that might be out
there and I was actually just just the
other day actually at this Hans Hawk
show at the new museum and
you know this is a really interesting
artist in the sense that he's been doing
these kinds of investigations in things
like these natural phenomena for a long
time this mound of dirt when an early
Earth work what happens if I put a pile
of dirt and a bunch of grass seed in an
art gallery the grass grows he is also a
detective so in the 1960s he uncovered
an enormous real estate scheme in New
York City and in fact the Guggenheim
wouldn't exhibit it because he said this
is an art right this is like police work
real estate work yeah hon tock is being
displayed in the in the new museum so
what are the outcomes of that right now
it's being consumed as entertainment and
this is again because of the structures
of the art world that people can only
recognize the finished product but the
fact is that Hans Hawk learned things
nobody else could knew right and there
was no mechanism for him as an artist to
bring that learning to the world he
could bring it to a journalist right he
could bring it to scientists but those
connections didn't exist I imagine you
might look at something like grass grows
and all kinds of ideas come to mind
right to the soil what kind of grass is
where's the light the temperature all
these things you have literacies that
Hans Hawk didn't he is just trying
something out but he's this investigator
so the question is what are the kinds of
data that are being crunched when an
artist is producing their work right
instead of
you know what we make as just art
there's also something important which
is our process how do we get to that
point so I'm calling these primary texts
and producer texts because if I call
them texts texts can be coded texts can
be analyzed and interpreted so artists
produce art that's true but in a much
bigger way we spend most of our time in
our process right sketching
thinking making memos making notes and
and we end up with lots and lots of
texts and tend to go unanalyzed artists
are taught to hide that stuff away right
don't you can't put that in the gallery
that's not part that's not our finished
product and then something else that art
produces of course is its effect on
people in a much bigger way lots of
people will watch a film and things are
happening in the sensibilities and in
the hearts of the people who experience
that film as the honest mention that I
also work as an impact producer right so
this is a made-up job that people
invented about ten years ago especially
specifically around social issue
documentaries which is how do you make a
film and then contextualize it so that
it can create social change I don't like
the I don't like the framework of impact
partly because it's a little colonial
the idea that like I'm a fast moving
object and I can impact another
community or society with with my
artwork I prefer engagement but impact
producer is the term there are companies
that do this for films they take your
film
they contextualize it they survey the
audiences they do social science around
how people perceive subject they try and
Bill agendas and engagement campaigns
sometimes to create policy change in
address legislators sometimes to create
community change or educational programs
but the point is that the film is no
longer the end product right the impact
now is the product
so you make an artwork it has an effect
on audiences and whether we like it to
or not
it hasn't if those audiences then have
an effect on our process okay so I'm
gonna listen to people at my show I'm
gonna listen to people who have talked
about my previous work and that's going
to inform the process and create this
cycle my previous art is also going to
inform my process my process is also
going to then touch on the audiences and
so this is the churn of your artistic
process the art itself is a very small
part of it and what I'm interested in is
what kind of data exists these effect
bubbles in this process bubble how can
we code that and how can we see the
knowledge that's being produced there so
for all kinds of artists there are these
kinds of texts this is what I call a
knowledge engine right an artist is
basically driver of a knowledge engine
but the artists can't all by themselves
capture all that knowledge there's much
too much in there so I'm working with
actors who have recognized that their
literacy in being able to embody and
verbatim perform real living people are
a knowledge engine for audiences to
identify implicit biases and how their
political preferences are actually
shaped in a spectacled environment so
Lindsey Graham went embodied by a female
actor people perceive this person very
differently and recognize that their
political preferences are not
necessarily all their own they have deep
structural implicit biases that are
affecting those things Lindsey Graham
gets away with things that this actor
cannot audiences respond very different
ways with the same group of actors we're
now doing this for the Democratic
primaries by body gender and race
swapping all the Democratic candidates
we're testing people and their own
perceptions of their political
preferences and
these are really really surprising the
fact is as I said we go in not knowing
and we aren't there to tell people who
to vote for but what we do find out is
that we're at people don't actually know
why they prefer the people in the
candidates that they do so there's their
preferences are being shaped by a lot of
factors that they're conscious of and so
what this does is it allows us to get
them to see and think more critically
and I think this is really important in
terms of resilience you know we live in
a democracy that is driven by spectacle
and therefore our choices are not really
our own if we are not critical and
conscious of the spectacle so I'm
working with a sculptor who is
interested in studying social dynamics
as form and here we are again this is a
choreographer looking for methods and
the qualitative data in what we call
applied choreography what does her
familiarity with body kinetics and the
movement of an organism have to do with
she's both a choreographer and a
demographer so the city of New York so
she also studies the movement of
populations the changes of community
changes of neighborhoods and what we're
trying to do is build a bridge between
those two ways of knowing so each of
these experiences performances
choreography is sculptures any artwork
any photograph any film can be coded
right we can code those and we can code
all of the producer texts that are made
in the mean time as well and from that
there's a data right that's the
information that's the but there might
be data types that we don't recognize
importantly data is not knowledge so
it's not enough just to gather the data
but we also have to synthesize it so
knowledge exists only within a
consciousness data can exist outside of
the world on its own all right we need
conscience we need a conscience or
consciousness to recognize knowledge
um and so I was wondering you know do
artists just go out and gather
information without recognizing that its
information and then skip ahead to
synthesizing into our works and vice
versa and I don't know you know to what
extent is synthesis within science not
acknowledging certain kinds of data
types not acknowledging or recognizing
even the presence of kinds of knowing
other than within the scientists
themselves the systems that they're
working and so I feel like we need each
other so artists when they get around
scientists record I don't know if you
noticed that we recognize all these
opportunities for synthesis like oh my
god I could I could make something out
of this right I could make a project out
of this like what you guys are doing is
really interesting to me I don't
understand it but I want to synthesize
right that's like the artistic drive
whereas you know think about Hans Hawk
or any of these other projects you a
scientist might look at me like oh my
god there's so much data in there right
we should draw some of that data out
should draw some of that information out
and I feel like there is a symbiosis
there that we are kind of lacking so you
know a prominent and really pertinent
example of this right now you know in
addressing babies the most pressing
issue of our time you know how can
research an intervention through artists
literacies be a meaningful component of
our response scientists have presented
all the evidence necessary to
demonstrate that this is happening and
yet there's no movement or very little
movement or it's just painfully
painfully slow so it isn't necessarily a
question of resources of where the
carbon is of what the temperature is but
is a question of relationships what is
our relationship to the earth to the
environment what are human beings
relationships to one another the earth
will be fine
it will get rid of us if it needs to we
won't write what we have to do is we
have to recognize our relationship to
the earth and that's something that can
really
power artists a lot of artists that I
talk to around this issue feel
disempowered because they feel like it's
a scientific issue scientists I talked
to feel disempowered because look we put
the evidence out there right this is
happening we know it's happening but
somehow the relationship to the
information to the knowledge just
doesn't seem to actually create a
traction so again I feel like this is
where this is not one or the other we
have to supplement and complement one
another's work this is the part of the
talk where artists audio audiences of
artists rather start to ask me about
instrumentalization and they get my
artists don't want to be
instrumentalized sometimes it's okay to
be instrumentalized because you know we
we do we can be tools but also artists
have this sense left over from that
previous map of our romantic past that
we're a little bit outside of things and
that we're a little bit like maybe we're
special you know that that it's
ineffable things that we do can't be
touched that they're innately human and
these are important ideas right because
everything that we do I don't think can
be quantified
so are we instrumentalizing or are we
identifying new value in the poetic in
the ineffable and the affective and this
is an important thing to maintain kinds
of instrumentalization that you may see
in art and again these are not
necessarily negative things but these do
compartmentalize art right stem to steam
I know how familiar you are with the
stem to schema movement but it you know
it's looking at the the stem emphasis in
especially American high schools and
saying well you're leaving out something
really important there the little crisis
I would say in stem to steam is that
nobody actually knows what the a for art
is actually supposed to be doing there
right so it's science technology
engineering and math with egg jammed in
there and often what artists get get
pigeonholed into doing is the third
thing data visualization and
communications so you guys gather the
data and you're like can you make us a
nice chart or
on our website for us and that's like
the only economic value artists feel
like they have right is the product of
our product of our process activism is
another one there's nothing wrong with
activism but it is a
compartmentalization of what artists are
actually capable of right the reason
artists have gotten to the point of
activism is because we know things how
did we come to learn those things human
centered design and then of course in
the contemporary art market which is you
know maybe not fully familiar here but a
super insidious problem it is the well
farm for the world's richest people
there are only two things that actually
generate wealth generate money from
nothingness it is contemporary art and
real-estate contemporary art is just you
know money from thin air it's
speculation and it drives economies and
artists are caught in this trap of
making work striving to get into a
gallery striving to gain a reputation
striving to become a brand striving to
be collected and then you're being
collected by frankly the people who are
creating some of the most significant
problems in the world right now so
expanding on these instruments
instrumentalization x' right is
important each of these has to be pushed
beyond and that's done by coming back
and recognizing that you know it is that
the value that artists ring is not
necessarily in the artwork but it is in
its process it is in our way of learning
in our way of knowing and trying to
figure out how we can value the process
of art making the same way we value the
process of science as scientists if you
just tell me that you're gonna spend the
next three four five or ten years
conducting research nobody has a problem
with that it's totally normal if I do
that as an artist that's not
economically sustainable and we don't
know what research looks like right so
as artists we have work to do to educate
ourselves about what our art based
research looks like and how do we
integrate it with other forms of
research so that
other researchers can recognize what we
do and see the value in it that was
quick
there's a lot but now I want to hear
from you take questions you can skip
back to any slides but please let me let
me have it
[Music]
yeah who's a it was really a question
right I think you know my understanding
of art is that it is it is leaping ahead
to synthesis because we don't have a lot
of vocabulary for data right we don't
have a lot of vocabulary information
whereas I mean I I did a lot of work
with USAID and I've done a lot of work
with organizations that rely on
scientific data but haven't synthesized
it like we don't know what this means we
just have the data and that's a pretty
big data approach yeah I think there's a
trend away from that which I'm hopeful
for but that's what I need you know it's
the sense it's just like is it enough to
just show us a map or a giant set of
data you know data points without
synthesizing what what is the meaning of
it and that often is when scientists and
art to come back to artists if can you
help me synthesize this can you help me
visualize it can you help me understand
it and I think I think of that we can
definitely do and then complement each
other yeah we actually only we did about
a three-day survey it was super quick
because I I was sent there for and this
is how artists often get a wedge in a
foothold in I was sent there to make a
film for US aid about something else in
Uganda and I said can I have three extra
days
and model this this motive research for
a problem that you guys had don't have a
solution for and so they connected me
with the African Wildlife Foundation and
said sure if you can figure out why
Uganda is seeing rising elephant
populations the elephant population in
Uganda has skyrocketed since the civil
war there meanwhile in Tanzania it is
continuing to plummet they're still
poaching and and yet the interventions
like the government interventions and
the community interventions are kind of
the same so something's happening in
Uganda that's not happening Tanzania so
we didn't get to do a comparative study
in Tanzania we did a kind of preliminary
study you know on a few days of just
talking with Rangers observing them
following them through their work
processes and then coding the footage
evaluating the footage my narrative lens
and again I didn't know what they didn't
know so I just gave them a report back
and said you know things that's amazing
about these Rangers is that they're
really patriotic they come from all over
Uganda and when they join the you got a
wildlife Authority that's like joining
the military in the United States right
so they describe their patriotism right
defending their natural resources
protecting their country's identity and
I was like that you know we're kind of
like oh that's cool like that's a great
thing and the UWA and the awf based in
the u.s. not the why life Preservation
Society but the other organization that
we were working for had never heard of
this they didn't know they didn't
realize patriotism was important so in
Uganda right I mean people are coming
from their their villages and from their
communities and there is no there's a
lot of kind of like kind of fractured
national identity and come they were
uniting around Uganda's Natural
Resources its wildlife and suddenly they
realized oh this is a way we can recruit
Rangers right
and that's one of the biggest things
they just need them Rangers they just
need more people who are out there
protecting the animals and recruitment
is an issue and they said well we should
recruit on patriotism we should recruit
do it for Uganda alright the way that we
recruit soldiers right it's it's you see
everywhere I mean you know there's so
much kind of militarism in America so
much patriotism the unites us as a
country Uganda has found that you can
unite themselves the country around
defending their there why are they also
anything that you could like to those
who want to visually in the terms of me
but like which is a little easier when
you understand those but like for people
I know that sound like there's
differences unless you do it yeah doing
it is the best way to do it right at
doing it is the best way to learn you
you develop literacy by trying to read
so you develop visual literacy by trying
to look and but that that key question I
would keep coming back to is what do you
know and how do you know it so when you
look at an image when you look at a
moving image
ask yourself like what do I know about
this image and then where did that
knowledge come from right I mean if I
see you know just skip quickly to a
slide like this all right you can look
at a slide like that and be like alright
it's three people sitting in a row but
what do I know about it okay I know
there's an authority figure right
I can recognize age difference I can
recognize some sort of context it's the
institutional context we can tell that
by the lighting we look at people's
facial expressions like here's how I
know what's happening in this scene
right this is the story that's unfolding
and then when you when you basically
split this up into categories of
knowledge alright so now I know how to
make an image that can tell the story I
want to tell
I mean the you know the the biggest kind
of failure in visual literacy that you
that you would see and when you see a
film it's like well that didn't make any
sense right because the audience
interpreted it one way and the
filmmakers intended it another and so
that's just a part of you know using the
wrong image right using the wrong shot
using the right angle and recognizing as
you would that every single detail
matters what is the camera angle what is
the lighting how clear is the sound all
of those things are components in our
understanding that's a great question
the ideal relationship you know artists
and scientists this is what we're
talking about this morning it's
adjacency I think it's just you know
there's a school science and there's a
school of art and how often do you see
each other alright how often do you just
sit next to each other and just kind of
you know cross pollinate partly those
artists and the scientists have to be
kind of armed with an openness when you
look at an artwork to say like hey this
is full of data which would be great
and an artist if you think there is it
is great what is it what is the data
help me right and so that's the
adjacency right so there should be
artists studios right there and they
should be there it should be a
playground in a sandbox that's where our
studios are right it's just we just play
and test and experiment and then you can
walk in and be like hey what are you up
to
that's it so it doesn't I don't know so
this is where I don't we don't need to
instrumentalize artists and have them
embedded as residents and do science cuz
no we're not gonna be good at the Hat
right but we could just be there and you
can see in our work what you see and we
can see in your work what we see and we
can work together every studio is
renaming itself a lab now yeah because
exactly for this reason I think you know
a lab has a scent I think there's a
technology
overtone to a lab right that where that
isn't in a studio and as artists start
to adopt technologies their Studios
become labs in terms of places for
experimentation play testing and
observation I feel like they're the same
dude we need a sign that's a good
question
what do you know and how do you know it
I think I mean I think that science I'm
gonna totally put my foot in my mouth
here I just yeah
my understanding of science is that it's
a much more kind of structured way of
learning right there are steps in the
process and there is peer review and
there's kind of mutual recognition of
what's good science and what's bad
science it doesn't always work you know
and I think that's sometimes it comes
down to the tools sometimes the people
but I think that where science literacy
is would be valuable is is understanding
also the human presence in science right
what again it everyone in this room is
full of implicit biases and and
structural prejudices that are not
necessarily bad things they are just
present all right I'm a white man born
and raised in the United States that
that is a loaded thing to be right and
there is a lot in there that as you kind
of work through it and grow through it
and recognize those biases you like oh
my gosh I haven't made a free choice in
my life you know it's like we aren't
really free of those things and so I
think for scientists that's a huge
challenge because you're trying to
create this objective view of the world
and just see it for its data points but
it's so hard to see data points outside
of our own head you know and and I don't
I don't necessarily buy into objectivity
so much as what I call multiple
subjectivity we need we need multiple
truths right to inform a common common
reality yeah well it's your become the
relation
illiteracy luzie of the Archon Titans
were like philosophy and the this
technology which would like question
projected yeah it's related I you know
this question that I that I keep coming
back to of what do you know and how do
you know it you know is his philosophy
is histology and I'm also not a
philosopher right so I couldn't tell you
who got there first or the history of it
it comes more from this recognition that
so much of what we're trying to do as
people is is based on a faith in
objectivity right a belief that there is
like something happening outside of
ourselves and of course there is
something happening outside ourselves
but how do we access it from within
ourselves and I think that's the
interesting place that artists actually
have you know can play a role art
certainly in the West has been looking
inward you know for the last few hundred
years it's become very reflective right
and very kind of inward looking and I
think that was the romantic reaction to
science looking outward and analyzing it
and breaking it apart and you know this
is again what kind of to our
conversation this morning we we do have
it's I think we can come back together
in some sense the challenge of that is
specialization right science is so
complex that you can't also be artists
full-blown artists at the same time so
we can work together right I also I it's
too late for me to become a full-blown
scientist right because there's so much
to learn there's so much history there's
so much involvement so my my
understanding of it is that we we should
have a philosopher in the room we should
have an artist in the room we should
have scientists in the room and we all
have to then train ourselves into an
openness that our specialties have I
think trained us away from this desire
adjacencies were being near each other
and that also cut I did a studio
becoming a lab but but what about that
screaming to get shared facilities like
if I'm thinking of the things that we do
we visualize a scientist we have special
techniques of looking at some
microscopes
different ways of seeing things and
scales that aren't that help us and then
we have ways of presenting some
visualization and I feel like we don't
and then we well create stuff well
becomes negotiating met incurring what
is the question being able to make stuff
you know like when you share an ability
to use the same you know whatever it
could be internal it you know laser
cutter or like you know is it beyond the
Jason see into like shared usually did
so that actually yeah you're working at
the same EB out with the same yeah so
one of the one of the implications of
the narrative research the film based
research that I came upon almost right
away was that the tools are insufficient
all right all the tools that I use for
filmmaking are made from making films
that I put out into the world as like
linear pieces of media and then there's
nonlinear media like algorithmic editors
that you can put on on the web but
they're all product based right it's all
about making a product and publishing it
so the first thing I started to think
about slyguy we need new tools for
filmmakers and then I started to imagine
every artist he's gonna come come up
against this if they complete they
reframe their practice as not art making
but as knowledge production they're
gonna need new tools scientists mate you
may already have those tools the thing
is I don't know or I know I need I need
technologists to help me build those
tools so again it's you know the
technologists are kind of serving a
market and the market tells them that
they need Adobe Premiere to cut yeah to
cut a feature film I need a thing that
makes this kind of map for me I need to
be able to kind of code things so some
of this stuff is actually based on
social scientists tools right the
concept of coding is a social science
concept and there are social science
pieces of software that let me kind of
code text and highlight images so I can
see in that like the beginning of like
coming into a science lab and be like oh
I could use this right artists are all
about repurposing things so I could
repurpose some of the tools that you're
using or maybe if we're adjacent to each
other we recognize that you need tools
that artists have used and maybe we need
hybrid tools I think that's like a third
component that is you know kind of to be
determined is is if we created these
kind of interdisciplinary like really
collaborative open sort of spaces I
think one of the first things that will
emerge from them are an entirely new
family of tools putting different
programs as well and I'm here for me is
like I'm not probably what you'll do
market at market oh I'm just like this
in-between residency's and there is a
lot of sensors that are on this kind of
research whatever
[Music]
and then you get business your way that
is very specific and I think this is and
we don't have the net as you say is that
to share this which is not the piece
it's not the time you are sharing they I
mean everyday life what do you do from
that that's really my question now today
so and that's a great question so artist
residency is especially the United
States are problematic right because so
if I get a year-long artist residency
right now in like in New York City there
are public artists and residences which
this is like the most progressive
program in the country where you can
spend a year in any city agency as an
artisan residence
you get like $5,000 and a cubicle right
if I must
scientist in residence if I'm a
demographer right in the demographics
office or if I'm you know Social
Sciences you're gonna get a salary yeah
yeah yeah so so part of it is that so on
the one hand it's like um artists have I
mean you know we can kind of tame it
into accepting that as okay and part of
that is because we aren't really sure
what our value is like I'm gonna go in
there and every artist so I work
specifically with artists in residence
so that so I'm their impact producer
okay
I do the coding on their audience texts
on their process texts on a producer
text and on their artwork and like draw
the data out of it and the artist is
like oh wow I never saw I never knew all
this that was happening and and then we
have to shape it to that agency or that
organization maybe they want to report
back right everybody wants a deliverable
right so that that the deliverable of an
artist residency tends to be like
decorations on the wall like feel-good
events and positive PR okay we're not a
big evil bureaucracy we have an
artist-in-residence so but if that
artisan residence was producing data was
producing knowledge right whether in the
form of reports or artworks standalone
art works on their own knowledge in an
audience right experience with the
public that's really economically
valuable that artists could do that
full-time and they could do it for a
salary that would change our culture if
artists were not in a state of economic
desperation where we are all best
friends until we have to stab each other
in the back to get the gallery show and
then nobody likes you anymore but now
you're collected by you know an oil
tycoon that's the reality artists face
and that's where art schools are
pointing them right because that's like
Career Services is how do you get a
gallery show you know how do you enter
the market instead of what do you do at
a residency to prove your worth and to
to transform that that agency right or
that organization wherever the residency
is
I just don't want to claim I know it
because I don't firsthand I've heard it
I've heard that you know before and I
just think ultimately we ultimately
capitalism is gonna insist that we have
deliverables right and you know
scientist it's a career with papers or
artists it's a career in a gallery and
but the thing that unifies us is that
all we want to do is learn right and and
build and build a body of knowledge that
we can pass on right we need an economy
that values that for both of us thank
you so much this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu